there's one thing I know about you it's
that Final Fantasy 7 is so near and dear
to your heart and I think that's maybe
that in frisbee are the two things that
brought us together but forget about
frisbee man we just got to play Final
Fantasy 7 remake it's kind of one of the
starring games at the show and it was
kind of crazy ride for me but like I
love the game you love the game what was
your reaction there's so much I like
about it there's a couple things I don't
but mostly I'd such a good takeaway from
this it does so many things right that
like I didn't expect it to take
seriously or do differently than the
first time around like first of all the
the reactor that we saw the Mokka
reactor it's like recreated so well down
to the enemies you fight the first guard
scorpion obviously they've turned into
like kind of a larger set piece but uh
it still feels great I have to agree
200% like the way that they have brought
the world to life is is great and it's
sort of one of those things where when I
used to play Final Fantasy 7 I'm sure
it's the same for you and everyone else
out there yeah it was low poly but like
we sort of like imprinted our own
interpretation of the details and from
our imagination and this doesn't leave
much to the imagination it's all kind of
right there it's a hit use the word but
it's gritty it's grimy right things are
a bit beaten down but it's also flashy
and like sparks fly everywhere when
attacks land a certain way it's it's a
visual sort of showcase and it's not
surprising it's taken this long to make
the game looking at it now I know like
that that was the biggest night away
from me - was that like going into this
you know they've only shown footage from
the make of reactor for the Mokka
reactors so far so I figured like this
game is still probably like three years
out or something like that like
depending on how much of the the first
chapter is being it's gonna fill me um
one thing that that really resonated
with me was like in the beginning for
the original obviously like Barrett you
know he like walks in the clouds body
and that's how they write how they put
the old videogame way of forming a party
yeah and so like all the little moments
where they're like entering between each
other and there's commentating on like
cloud being a traitor or like working
for shin or like all that stuff actually
happens pretty organically and like it's
very fitting to the original characters
yeah um and like the voice acting is I
don't know sigh like cloud I'm not I'm
not sure how I feel about Barrett
you know I'll give him the chance to
yeah to grow on me but before this demo
I got to say like Barrett's voice was
super aggravating to me and I was just
like so ready to write him off but there
were moments like you're right like when
he was confronting cloud when he was
like you got to place the bomb right and
cloud was having some hesitation for a
reason or another and you know it was
just that that exchange felt felt real
it didn't feel like the over-the-top you
know Tropic Thunder Robert Downey jr.
voice that we've been hearing that's in
there it's a little bit goofy but I
think at the end of the day that too
it's interesting to see how just like
serious this game is taking the world
and it's characters like they're all
being treated like not just sort of like
archetypes that are cut and pasted in
there I mean we have only seen a handful
of minutes but you kind of get a sense
of who they are and then like what
defines them maybe that's just because
we've already played this you know the
original and I know all that stuff but
yeah but but to that point like
replaying this game now like it's it's
almost like a dream of Final Fantasy 7
it's like a different version of it that
that didn't exist before and it's for
that reason alone I'm super interested
to see where it goes but I also want
talk about combat really quick because
that's sort of like I think one of the
biggest change is happening to the game
it is a hybrid of you know real time not
really turn-based because it's not like
the enemy is taking turns necessarily
but I thought it worked really well you
know you didn't have to necessarily tap
into those abilities you don't even have
to slow down time because you can also
map them to a single button which is
nice but you could also take your time
pause issue a command a cloud issue a
command to bear it or switch to berry
really quickly and I don't know about
you but I got that flow down really
quick and yeah that was very encouraging
mm-hmm yeah news like I found myself
like you know specifically digging
through each ability to see which it did
and like which ones added more stagger
damage to the enemy and then once I did
that I switched back to cloud and do
like the braver attack or something from
massive damage I was like this is great
like I'm just switching back and forth
between these guys really quickly like I
can't imagine what its gonna be like
when you have three players you have to
balance all of that yeah it should
definitely be interesting I mean we've
only seen a glimpse of the game we know
that the entirety of the first game will
take place only in Midgar
Yoshinori quitarse gave us a
presentation running through some more
details about the game you know we do
know for certain like yesterday during
the presentation they said you'll have
two blu-rays worth of data they were
able to confirm
no it will be to blu-ray discs I mean
you know what they said could have been
interpreted in different ways like we're
talking about a download are we talking
about a single layer or dual layer
blu-ray I think if they're doing - it
must be - dual layers because otherwise
they could just anyway I'm getting
technical with this but it's going to be
a big massive game they say it's gonna
have as much content as a traditional
like Final Fantasy sequel like a new
game which sounds nuts I don't know I
get the impression that this is going to
be more than a few episodes they were
saying that you know the only reason
that we're doing this is because we
don't want to cut anything from the game
and that's why the first game is just
Midgar and it's going to be substantial
because they're really doubling down on
the world and the characters jesse in
particular who you could I don't know
about you but when we played the bye
played the original game there was
always this hint of like oh yeah she's
kind of like flirtatious with cloud like
she's having fun with him here you kind
of get a bit more of that and I almost
wonder yes yes yes about like your
relationship you know tithi you guys
close son everyone you know yeah it's
only indication or this demo is any
indication like yes they're right when
they say the first game the first
chapter will be a whole game like it
fully
yeah maybe 4050 our experience just in
Midgar line yeah because yeah the
reactor was super fleshed out yeah it
was really good looking we've only seen
a glimpse but I'm super excited
are you yeah anyway excited for it for
reasons I didn't even anticipate yeah it
looks like it's doing justice to the
original while also you know kind of
spreading out to do its own thing as
well and then it works you're very much
working we have no distance from this
demo we just got back planning it we are
admitted Final Fantasy fanboys so take
all this for what you will and of course
there are plenty of the video games at
e3 besides Final Fantasy 7 remake so
stay tuned a game spot for all that news
and info
you
[Music]